voici presque fini pinocchio allez
quelque chose de mobile trou ton père ici
de papa
mais ils vont à un fils que je sentais que le toit est
succès un fils est né sont
est devenu papa
tu aimes pinocchio comme je l'ai fait pour moi
bouton mon fils bonjour
emmener mon fils à l'école pinocchio mais
comme pas fini de manquer de
par rapport à papa
on retrouve le bacchus tu as dit
56 qui m'a dit laissez moi me présenter je suis là
renard beau nom j'ai été
belle pourquoi tu ne me dis pas un peu
Qu'est-il arrivé
Je prends le film qui fait face à un
fontaine ou rien tu sais aide un peu
mensonges maintenant le nez grandit
tu ne te souviens pas des garçons qui veulent
faire leur propre truc
tôt ou tard si je me repens tais toi
[Musique]
Voici
un homme arrive ne t'inquiète pas
dans un beau pays on l'appelle le pays des
jouets
faisons un peu de magie
le président est un enfant comme tous
autres